y'all want more of this shitty game
y'all enjoyed it so much last time I
played it so why not make another one
the comments are practically begging for
it let's see who else play this game oh
that's right [ __ ] everyone oh look
there's money in the background what a
creative and original idea where could
you have possibly gotten it from but
I'll play some more I'll have some fun
we'll have some laughs anyway let's play
some more
looks like PewDiePie is depressed again
he stares at the games it's like staring
into the void another [ __ ] video he
thinks what the [ __ ] is that Sam it's
triggering me we got to come up with a
good title
let's just call it what it is clickbait
oh we gotta make a video
let's do up stick the classic murderous
look
sarcastic comment hey everyone leafy
here I'm going to kill myself tonight
that's all we have time for
okay let's edit this baby literally I do
the same [ __ ] just throw that [ __ ]
together no one gives a [ __ ] who publish
that [ __ ] Frederick do you want to shut
okay oh look we might find it like a
meme here video game company buys cats
haha what am i doing oh yeah I'm waiting
for the video to render why am I not
tabbing out and watching porn really
interesting what does it price who
edited this video
ha ha ha ha ha it's so bad at least
never [ __ ] with a guy that knows
Photoshop oh what a nice cowboy hat
Elise oh wait it's a dick what is peopIe
doing beauty pie beauty pot you got to
make another video but I don't want to
make another video I just want to play
games for fun
shut the [ __ ] up here if I make another
[ __ ] video oh god I gotta make
another video of horrific horrifying
sure
now at least that's an honest title
dancing greeting I got that one hey
how's the cone that's it that's all I
had time for what a piece of [ __ ] video
oh man this recording didn't really turn
out well
maybe I should scrap it and try again
that's hilarious
these peasants will watch what I give
them
okay so you can see how popular the
games are all right we're just gonna
pick the most popular game to play
because [ __ ] having your own personality
and adding value wait what what Rancho
is macaws it got released holy [ __ ]
I gotta get a video I'm right [ __ ]
now the sooner the video gets up the
more views I will get this [ __ ] quality
okay um weight and perfect weight hello
how's it going breasts murderous look Oh
God
uh loading the funny as to me Oh funny
comment I have a micropenis why is mom
just staring they're so awkward she's
just standing there
[ __ ] off mom oh oh [ __ ] oh god no we
failed our grades oh god mom it's gonna
be so super pissed my life is over go to
sleep go to sleep faster [ __ ] no no no
no no mom please I'm losing subscribers
mom you don't understand
I want to report a pot one day mom why
would you play this game I'm not on it
clean all right it's time to move out
[ __ ] you mom you're not gonna ruin my
career I don't even say goodbye
I [ __ ] never got to pay for our own food
and [ __ ] energy drinks a lot a lot of
energy drinks you think I actually have
a personality okay we got to add as many
tags in the title as possible
cuz more tags into title means more
views gameplay walkthrough let's play
playthrough tutorial play let's 1080p
60fps like anyone gives a [ __ ]
HD gone sexual
oh we're playing a hurricane let's do a
music intro how's it going bros my name
is PewDiePie
I do this for a living you can tell
right come on this game is not even
realistic where's the part about
obsessing about analytics and looking at
the stats um how many views you got go
to sleep wake up make a video repeat
every [ __ ] single day it's funny cuz
I'm just using this game to call out all
the [ __ ] see even if the game isn't
that funny
I can still have fun with it even if a
video is different every day I have a
fanbase that except the videos
regardless and I appreciate that because
that gives me a lot of freedom and it
makes me happy so thank you so much for
watching another video don't forget to
Like subscribe GE Google+ Facebook
Twitter and Pinterest thank you so much
and as always stay awesome press I'm
sure that everyone who played this game
is playing it because they think it's a
really good game and not because it's
gonna get a lot of clips on YouTube
because of the title of the game
and you tell me right now that is not a